l'ugtt est absente et trop longtemps
alice certaines choses méritent tout ton
attention il ne faut pas négliger c'est
m
dépêche toi
lorsque le jour devient la nuit que le
ciel et l'océan sont unis le glas que
l'on entend sonner nous fait oublier
l'heure du thé ont cet instant
redoutable avant la rime du dénouement
elle reviendra au pays des merveilles
il remontera le cours du temps le temps
est une personne il vaut mieux ne pas
l'avoir pour et demi s'il vous plaît
monsieur le chapelier est en danger
jeune fille votre temps s'est écoulé
tout cela n'est pas rassurant
bonjour à l'iss
permettez moi de vous offrir ce présent
ah ben